tomorrow is juneteenth the historic date
now a federal holiday marking the end of
slavery in the u.s
local celebrations here in the valley
have already started hector mejia is
live this afternoon at the cosmopolitan
with some details heifer good afternoon
hey there good afternoon and it's been a
day full of celebration here at the
first ever
juneteenth jubilee breakfast and it's
set to become an
annual event it was put together by the
local naacp and hosted by the
cosmopolitan
bringing together community leaders
activists
members and all coming together as we
all talk about unity and commemorate
juneteenth
the holiday celebrates the emancipation
of the last african american slaves in
texas in 1865
that was two and a half years though
after the emancipation proclamation was
signed to free slaves
now the holiday has long been observed
by the african-american community
but overlooked by history until recently
for us it just means that finally the
world
is recognizing us as a people of color
minorities that we have come a long way
and that this
is our official independence day and
it's nice to have this day recognized
just for
us and for us to be able to educate the
rest of our
partners around this country that we are
one and a little bit about our heritage
and our history
just yesterday it became a federal
holiday after
president joe biden signed a bill
commemorating the end of slavery in the
u.s
it's the first new national holiday
since 1983 back when president
ronald reagan added the martin luther
king jr holiday
as you can see celebration still
continuing out here juneteenth
will be the nation's 11th federal
holiday but as we i just mentioned
these celebrations have been going on
for quite some time here
in the valley reporting live from the
cosmopolitan hector mejia
8 news